Are you one of 5 in 10 Caucasians that suffers
from an embarrassing and debilitating genetic
affliction?
Can you not leave the house without hitting
or raping a woman?
Unable to resist the urge to belittle, shame
and sexually harass your female colleagues
at work?
Did you spend your childhood beating the shit
out of your friends at barbeques?
Do you still spend your social gatherings
revealing your spectacular abs and whipping
out your member to compare?
Then I am afraid, what you feared is true,
you suffer from a horrific disease, “maleness”.
Don’t worry my disgusting, hairy friend,
there is a cure.
“Anti Man”, proven to reduce your testosterone
and eradicate your masculinity within 30 days,
or your money back.
Now with added soya!
This is the message that a growing number
of gender activists and corporations that
wish to adopt a virtuous facade, most recently
Gillette, would have us believe.
But what’s the reality here?
Based on social norms that have been developed
over thousands of years, underpinned by biology
and using empirical evidence I seek to rationalise
masculinity and answer an important question,
is being masculine bad for society?
A good start would be finding out what is
masculinity anyway?
It is entirely distinct from an individual’s
biological sex.
Sure masculine traits stem from a person’s
biological sex, but if we’re getting technical
then masculinity itself is a social construct
that describes a set of traits innately present
in most men.
The same traits, however, can often be found
in women, not always, and often to lesser
extremes.
The traits of masculinity can also differ
slightly between world cultures, but the core
traits that define a masculine man are universally
consistent.
What are those traits?
Stoicism, resilience, strength, courage, independence
and assertiveness.
Before judging men for being too assertive,
occasionally resorting to violence or too
stoic for not displaying emotion.
It’s important to understand where these
traits actually come from.
The traits themselves are not social constructs.
Men don’t become masculine just because
we tell them that “crying is for girls”
and “man up”.
Masculinity in men may be enhanced or even
enforced in certain cultures by social pressures
but make no mistake, masculine traits originate
from our biology, constructed over a period
of 200,000 years.
Long ago nature’s doctrine of survival of
the fittest decided the most efficient way
to perpetuate a species through reproduction
and ensure its longevity is by dividing each
species into two sexes.
This division is seen across the entire animal
kingdom.
What can also be observed in all animal species
and humans are the different roles inherent
within each sex.
With the exception of the male pregnancy witnessed
in the Syngnathidae family of fish, the young
of all species are incubated by the female
sex.
It, therefore, makes sense, logistically,
that females evolved to have behavioural and
physiological traits that are conducive to
the healthy development and loving nurture
of their young.
Empathy, emotional awareness, patience and
tenderness.
Obviously, it was also vital that females
never put themselves or their young in a situation
of danger, so evolution naturally put that
onus on the other sex, males.
Males developed a greater aptitude for physical
strength and the natural courage to hunt to
provide food for their tribe and women.
Men evolved to have aggressiveness, resilience
and assertiveness, underpinned by undying
competitiveness so they could compete against
rival males and protect their tribe from other
scarier tribes who had larger, pointier sticks.
Sure those traits were essential pre-civilisation,
but why can’t we get rid of them today through
the systematic emasculation of men?
Are they not redundant in the 21st century?
Don’t such traits cause nothing but toxicity
and evil throughout our societies?
These are the edicts that many social justice
warriors seek to mandate on modern men.
Masculinity is a shifting social construct,
its nature has mutated over the generations.
Today it is more socially acceptable than
ever before in the history of humanity for
a man to show emotion and share his feeling
with his friends, for a man to cry, for a
man to choose another man as a sexual partner
and marry him.
All these are truly amazing and undeniably
positive advances towards a better, more harmonic
world and none of these things degrades a
man’s masculinity.
But these are not the traits that authoritarian
leftist activists are trying to suppress.
What is under fire is the more assertive,
domineering and tough side that is biologically
present in every man, to varying degrees.
Such traits and the actions which can be associated
with them are too often referred to as toxic
masculinity.
The issue here is that so-called “toxic
behaviour” is not endemic to masculine men
or even men.
Evil and malice are present across all demographic
cross-sections of society.
There’s no denying that men commit crime
and nobody would claim that either sex is
perfect.
But before shunning masculinity it’s imperative
that we understand how dangerous this can
be, for one simple reason.
Masculinity does more good than bad, for everyone,
men and women.
And not just a little bit more good.
For every bad deed a man commits in the world
I would propose that well over a thousand
good deeds are carried out by other masculine
men, every day.
Only a fool would argue that men never do
bad.
In 2014 73% of those arrested in the US were
male.
But to live in a society where the majority
of good men are publically shamed for the
crimes of the minority of bad men is damaging
to the mental health and sense of purpose
of men the world over.
Especially when the underlying and natural
biological traits of the male species are
being labelled as the cause of all these evils.
It also pulls all the attention away from
the many beautiful things that most masculine
men achieve every day, which vastly outnumber
the horrendous things a much smaller portion
of masculine men do.
Do not forget that masculinity was born from
a natural desire for men to provide for and
protect their family.
When a man takes his daughter to school, gives
her a kiss and wishes her a good day, that
is masculinity doing good.
When a man works over ten hours a day to feed,
cloth and shelter his family, that is masculinity
doing good.
When a firefighter rescues a child from a
burning building, that is masculinity doing
good.
When a policeman arrests a perpetrator of
domestic abuse, rape or murder, that is masculinity
doing good.
When a young man shields his sweetheart with
his jacket when it rains, that is masculinity
doing good.
When a surgeon saves a person’s life through
open heart surgery, that is masculinity doing
good.
When Alexander Fleming invented penicillin,
saving millions of lives, that was masculinity
doing good.
When millions of brave men gave their lives
to prevent fascism and tyranny from engulfing
our world in 1914 and 1939, that was masculinity
doing good.
The truth is, trying to control the tiny minority
of bad men by quashing masculinity in all
men is an exercise in futility and idiocy.
Bad men will not stop being bad because they
become less masculine, they will only become
more frustrated and frustrated people are
more likely to commit injustices than content
people.
The result will be fewer good masculine men
to stop the bad men and bad women from being
bad.
Masculinity and femininity are the two pillars
that underpin a cohesive, progressive and
productive society that is beneficial to all.
Shorten or remove either one of those pillars
and society as we know, the society that we’ve
built over thousands of years and the society
that we’ve protected against tyranny and
evil will come crashing down beneath our very
feet.
Yet how does modern society thank these everyday
incredible men?
They are widely vilified, on social media,
in the press, in schools and in popular culture,
and now even in advertisements, the historic
bastion of greedy capitalism.
This has resulted in men committing suicide
at three times the rate of women.
And these men who help build and improve our
society every day face other challenges at
an alarming ratio.
Men are twice as likely to be the victim of
a violent assault or robbery.
3.5 times more likely to be murdered.
96% of workplace fatalities happen to men
Men are 5.6 times as likely as women to be
incarcerated.
86% of the homeless population is male Boys
have been lagging behind girls in educational
achievement since 1991, and the gap is widening
every year.
This points to a far more concerning fact,
that the increasing shaming of masculinity
in schools is causing a crisis in the development
of young men.
Competitive games that are deemed too aggressive
such as British bulldog or tag and dodgeball
have been long since banned in many school
playgrounds in the West.
A few schools in Britain are even considering
banning the sport of rugby, a fundamental
part of masculine development in young boys
since 1823.
Whilst these games and sports can on rare
occasions cause injuries, they play a vital
role in developing character and a strong,
competitive attitude in young boys that will
enable them to, later in life, compete in
the workplace and protect their family.
In fact, competitiveness, which is predominantly
a masculine trait, has been mostly eradicated
from our schools in the West.
During sports day and other events, everyone
is given a participation award, there is no
winner or loser.
I failed miserably at sports, I finished last
on sports day and I wasn’t given a trophy
for taking part, I got nothing, and you know
what it taught me?
That next time I need to try harder, that
I would never amount to anything unless I
put the effort in and practised, not just
in sports, but in every aspect of life.
That was one of the most important lessons
I have ever learnt.
In the same way, that over-sanitisation during
youth leads to a weak immune system, mollycoddling
children is not how strong societies are built,
doing so is in reality, a threat to a strong
society for the next generation.
Nowhere is misandry more rife than in Swedish
schools.
Several pre-schools and primary schools in
Sweden have gone to extensive efforts to remove
the words “boy” and “girl” from the
children’s vocabularies, preferring the
gender-neutral pronoun “hen”.
A legal amendment in 1998 legally mandated
all schools in Sweden to actively work against
gender stereotypes.
This all sounds very utopian in theory, but
in practice, it is nothing short of brainwashing,
that leads to a difficult and confusing progression
into teenhood and adulthood for these children.
They are being taught to ignore basic science,
go against the natural biological pull of
their own body.
This will only achieve to create a generation
of frustrated, passive men.
Without being free to indulge in their masculinity
in the playground and at home then these boys
will grow into men who are unable to compete
in the workplace and in personal matters,
unable to defend themselves and their family.
If evidence of this brainwashing were needed
then look no further than Seafarer’s Preschool
in Sweden.
Where boys and girls as young as one are actually
segregated so their natural gender roles can
be systematically indoctrinated out of them.
Boys are made to play with toy kitchens and
give each other massages.
Girls are forced to practice shouting “No!”.
A so-called “gender specialist” is employed
by the preschool to pick up on and coerce
boys who refuse to partake in feminine activities
such as dance.
Boys are encouraged to wear dresses and the
teachers celebrated when one particular girl
who used to be “very girlie” according
to her mother, was reared by the preschool
to become more boisterous and her parents
noted that she had become more “cheeky and
defiant” at home.
Shockingly it was observed that when the children
were no longer forced to play with toys typically
favoured by the opposite gender that the boys
reverted to playing with cars and the girl's
dolls.
The boys shouted and hit more.
The staff at the preschool says this is not
okay.
Well golly, it’s almost as if their biology
compels them to adhere to their natural gender
roles and that forcibly preventing them from
embracing this is actually child abuse, just
a thought.
An inability to protect his family is not
the only issue an emasculated man will face
in adulthood.
What is just as crucial, is a man’s ability
to lead and inspire his family, particularly
his children.
When a masculine presence is stripped away
from an otherwise nuclear family unit the
consequences can often be disastrous.
There is no rule that children can't thrive
in non-nuclear families, different family
setups can absolutely nurture incredible children.
But looking solely at fatherlessness the statistics
show a clear trend.
Children who grow up without a father figure
are twice as likely to drop out of school,
twice as likely to become obese and four times
as likely to succumb to poverty.
They are also more likely to commit crime,
go to prison, abuse drugs and alcohol.
Fatherless girls are seven times more likely
to fall pregnant as a teen.
After all this rhetoric there’s an important
distinction that must be made.
I, myself and I sincerely hope many other
men out there have no desire to strip men
of their right to choose how they want to
develop through life.
If men want to go against their natural masculinity
or even seek to abolish it, then we should
all work to protect their rights to do so
and me, I say more power to you.
But it’s so very important that men have
that right to choose.
Just like freedom of speech, it’s essential
that as a society we work to protect a man
or a woman’s right to live how they want
to live, be who they want to be, walk how
they want to, talk how they want to and wear
whatever they damn well desire.
But when it comes to a man’s right to fully
embrace and assert his masculinity in a positive
way it’s labelled as “sexist male privilege”
by the media and the tribal activists on the
internet.
In doing so, a man’s right to choose to
embrace masculinity is being eroded more and
more so every year.
That’s why it's vital that when companies
such as Gillette seek to tar all men with
the same discriminatory brush and suppress
our right to embrace our biology, that we
fight to retain our rights to be whoever the
hell we want to be.
Masculinity should be empowered, not shamed
and belittled.
Men everywhere must continue to show the world
that overall, masculinity is a force for good,
not evil.
Never be ashamed of your masculinity my hairy
friends because it built the roads beneath
your feet.